you guys must have really liked working
together because you're working together
again in the masterpiece i had met tommy
was so one time you did he was exactly
like
how i expected him to be yes did he did
he come on set he had a cameo right
he does have a cameo it was contractual
very it was one of the oddest
days i've ever had on set um can you
please tell me about it um
i don't know if i should reveal too much
uh
his range is
not very fast
so he played a version of himself
although he was called han ray and um
and i was basically playing him so there
were was tommy versus tommy in a way uh
very odd you are tearing me apart up how
does he feel about the movie
he has actually not seen the movie yet
uh-huh yeah either but greg cestero
though the actor from the room saw it
and thought it was incredible i read his
book it's very it's our movie's based on
his book right yeah right what's your
role in the movie are we allowed to
reveal anything of that i play myself
hey i play myself in the movie but not
in this current time back in the time of
the room okay is when i when i play it
and uh
i did a lovely scene with uh dave
and uh and and allison yeah i love you
good kid
tearing me apart
thank you so much
[Music]
you